ces lignes effectivement d'un scénario
catastrophe à bollène où nous allons
tout de suite retrouvé nos envoyés
spéciaux on compte plus d'un millier de
sinistrés
reportage d'anne consignes est et
jean-françois giorgetti la petite ville
de bollène savait qu'elle allait être
envahis par les eaux parce qu'en amont
d'autres villages avant elle avait
éprouvé la crue mais une inondation
pareil à bollène on ne s'y attendait pas
tout de même des évacuations préventives
avaient été effectués mais toute la
matinée les pompiers ont tenté de
s'assurer que personne ne restait en
danger dans le centre-ville travail
difficiles les véhicules n'avance que
lorsqu'il y à peu d'eau et pour les
barques et courants sont traîtres on est
aspiré et l'embarcation a été se
projeter contre les murs les voitures on
a littéralement décollé sur des voitures
on ait la chance de s'en sortir tous à 1
m
un peu plus loin
l'eau atteint un mètre 80 impossible d'y
aller à pied
en plein milieu d'une rue une voiture
aux essuie-glaces toujours en
fonctionnement
il faut absolument s'assurer que
personne n'est resté à l'intérieur
heureusement la voiture est vide sans
doute abandonné dans la précipitation
monsieur papa vous demander ce que vous
venez de faire la maligne et sa passion
et enfin je vais monter au sexe et sa
belle-mère ya encore pas mal de bébé
aussi là bas
enfin dans certains quartiers de bollène
là où le courant est trop fort il a
fallu recourir à l'hélicoptère
jusqu'à cet appareil ont survolé la zone
à pied en barque ou en hélicoptère au
total plus de mille habitations ont été
évacuées mais la masse doute se déplace
lentement et en cette fin de matinée
il restait encore des maisons isolées